welcome back it's a Jim Norton and Sam
Roberts Sebastian Bach is coming in it's
got a new book out called 18 and life on
Skid Row Sebastian but really welcome
how's it going sit down you know damn
shoulder I don't like this is Dan Soder
huh welcome to the show man how's it
going
well we were just on a Fox and Friends
I was watching you this morning I saw
Reb near the show oh yeah we were on we
got a do morning radio high but then the
next guest that grow on Fox in French
Soho for you fine no way when the blonde
I don't chicks dig singers I don't know
if she was the weather girl or which I
think she's new on Fox and Friends but
she was like she was like I'm a big
Sebastian Bach fan I think they had to
tell her to cool it off after he left
okay next my life my wife is gonna go
kick yeah yeah but um she was into him
right that were you there she was into
him right yeah oh no Facebook friends
Facebook I'll wreck everything
yeah really does [ __ ] I lost so many
friends on this election you did yeah
like a fight stick up for Hillary I just
get attacked mm-hmm it was the same on
bullet people were just [ __ ]
unfriendly Cho
totally yeah totally screaming at each
other I don't do politics on face I'd do
it in real life on Facebook is too
exhausting some guy I defended Hillary
Clinton and then some guy your buddy
Jamison goes on my page and calls my
uncle of a [ __ ] [ __ ] my uncle likes
fighting yeah well you think the [ __ ]
world is flat and [ __ ] you're a more I
go my uncle's like 72 he lives in like
Colorado what it's like you can't call
my uncle of [ __ ] [ __ ] as your a your
unfriended me he's like sorry man you
know I like dude I'm done with you look
after everything that you've done and
everything that you've been through
you're still dealing with the Facebook
[ __ ] no one escapes then no no one
escaped and it's random family members
that get it the worst cousins uncles
it's not [ __ ] people you want to get
it
yeah old high school friends that you
wish you could delete you
I spear I gosh how's about this like cuz
you have to use your real name you got
to put your old-school so then you get
people that you haven't seen since
you're like 12 like giving you advice
like now yeah I like dude I haven't
[ __ ] seen you since I was 12
would you read like I know literally I
guess we're not 12 years old anymore
delete away like III read like a
smartass comment on one of my photos and
who's know you anymore dude who's this
troll and it's my uncle just like I not
agent 2l are you saying it it's my
[ __ ] arm is that wrong
yeah I try not to engage on Facebook
it's just too exhausting because Twitter
at least there's a certain amount of
characters on Facebook it just gets too
long and I know most of those people
sort of disappears right like this this
sort of thing of like it's on your page
and people see it at different times it
just feels permanent that is the form of
Facebook it's just so easy to leave like
an attack under under a picture yeah
yeah you have a Twitter you can like
reply but you can't leave like a hundred
right everybody doesn't see you know the
replies that's right that's right but
your highlight you like your captioning
the photo yourself that's right yeah
there's like a hundred dick [ __ ] what
do you think you're so good the see more
the see more button on Facebook's always
a trouble stone are you on my page yeah
yeah go away there's more there's more
than just these three sentences and you
click see more it it goes into a [ __ ]
it's like a scroll like this is way too
much but we knew when you spend as much
time as you did writing this book like
it's a long book and you wrote it
yourself
yeah like aren't you tapped out as far
as writing like it's all in the book
don't [ __ ] worry about my session
Alicia tell me on your show I have a new
book called 18 live on Skid Row and it's
in stores today and it's the number one
selling book on Amazon rock and roll
category hey yeah
tell your friends on Facebook take it
yeah and uh just you know writing a book
entails countless hours just sitting in
front of your computer screen and
and other than that literally just
torturing everybody around you like good
be quiet go you can't be in this side of
the house I gotta write a book [ __ ]
there's gotta be good
you can't [ __ ] watch TV in the living
room you gotta go in the basement
why do you why didn't you get a call
writer you did the whole thing yourself
you didn't want anybody's good okay I
like making money we gotta give this guy
that you don't know a third [ __ ] that
how about I [ __ ] write the
[ __ ]
all right how long did it take you to
write it for years okay you know I was
reading it and as a little I was bummed
out by one thing like I got to this
point in the early on in the book I
really thought I was gonna hear a story
about you [ __ ] Christina Applegate
when she was 16 right well he almost
although and then like and then you're
like yeah and we were called goobers
like right after she like started I'm
married with children and you met her in
a club and everything
no she just she was a skid row fan right
that's what it was that she was on the
side of the stage yeah Bon Jovi Tour
like for our show and we just couldn't
believe it but like and it's like yeah
when we kept in contact a little bit and
I'm like oh [ __ ] what am i reading here
and then he fesses up and says we made
out a little bit and cuddled but I know
fornication I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
lie no fornication was anybody mad about
anything you put in the book I don't
know it's only been out a couple hours
okay it's dramatic a lot of 9 a.m. 1 to
10 well I got a little 50-minute minutes
into this day usually I'm sure somebody
is yeah stuff leaks out though that
about somebody I say this over and over
in the book you know everything's dated
as most of its long time ago thirty
years ago
this is way before the internet way
before cellphones I just sit down and
like remember this [ __ ] you know with
all the stuff we were doing that wasn't
exactly easy but you know kick everybody
out of the house do you yeah do you
think there's anybody that's gonna flip
to a certain part of the book like
guessing where they are in your life
like I bet there's some [ __ ] about me in
this part of the book yes and just dive
right in as you said Eddie trunk is the
guy that flips through looking through
his name
[ __ ] am i well the whole books about you
dude 450 pages all you man I I was as I
was as googling you and stuff and the
Bon Jovi stuff is what is really was the
promo leak or whatever well that was
like a New York Post yeah like it's not
bad for the book no but listen again
this was a long time ago there's an
incident that you're referring to in
1989 we used to have these ends of tour
hijinx and the New York Post headline
yesterday yes Jon Bon Jovi's dad
threatened to kill Sebastian Bach
there's a nice headline it's a great and
lovely headline but that that refers to
a very specific incident that happened
where I learned if you insult one
Italian mm-hmm the whole [ __ ] family
comes at you I see the father the
brother the everybody and the road crew
so why did you insult him what happened
cuz he whipped [ __ ] he dumped my head
and a vat of ice milk hmm I don't want
to give away the whole book that's right
where's ice milk on tour that's an odd
thing the end of tour hai genki member
that [ __ ] where bands at grease up the
drumsticks I didn't know they do that no
I know they do I was on the roll of
Pantera once and I put my mic up to sing
and my mais my mouth starts burning
interesting what the [ __ ] and I wipe it
off my lives of my eye i ah and they're
all laughing and they doused my mic in
Tabasco wipe it off it's going in my
eyeballs everybody's loving on stage
what's wrong with it uh well you [ __ ]
bastard
how long did it last how long were your
eyes my ass goes hot like and you get it
in her eyes I don't know I'd stay I
smell could have helped out Duncan ice
milk with a giant ice milk would have
had everything I was walking in the
stage Louisville Kentucky yeah
lights were out and I feel about six
dudes
grabbed me I don't know what's going on
and just dunk my head and hold me under
in a vat of like freezing cold
I smell as the first song is starting
yeah
and I'm supposed to be up there for the
first verse and I'm under the stage and
you know when you jump into waters too
cold you get that vertigo yeah I was
like what before and I run out and the
bats come what are you doing I got milk
all over me but but you gotta read the
rest of it
yeah after yeah yeah well the book again
is called a teen in life on Skid Row but
you still have like beefs I was reading
that you had some kind of rivalry with
Michael sweet who's a singer all I know
is that in the history of headlines yeah
on blabbermouth
yeah Bach slams [ __ ] sweet the greatest
headline alright that's a name I have my
sex tape what box slams [ __ ] sorry nice
[ __ ] good head woman yeah yeah say
that it yeah box man sweet slams [ __ ]
sweet yeah what a cool dad what a
headline Dan tries to slam [ __ ] okay
yeah are you still getting into into
rivalries with people in music I don't
get in I don't what if I read something
online yeah that has a little checkmark
next to it so I know it's the dude
saying it mm-hmm I figure you can say it
in person right right yeah if I say some
[ __ ] I expect people to say what's up
alright Bon Jovi's dad as I didn't
threaten to kill you you know he's
waiting outside yeah that's true
what did Michael sweet to do I don't he
threw a Bible at me I was wearing yellow
and black stripes cy from head to toe
[ __ ] amazing look
why did he do that long as he believes
in God he has a clergy Anna band well is
melded into one he's Michael sweet
exactly
guys throwing Bibles you better start
praying he's my bro singer as far as I
know yeah the Bible throw my can Michael
sweet no that's his thing that's how he
ends every show with a [ __ ] witty in
version a King James Version I didn't
understand was I what the whole fight
was about with Michael sweet from
striper apparently said something online
about some cover of a Skid Row song and
they see said it was better than when
Sebastian did it I think I don't know
it's not why I that's not why I slam
[ __ ] sweet why did you slam Lizzy sweet
because he goes plus he's a tool to boot
oh you're like [ __ ] yeah I'm [ __ ] too
long I'm gonna both show you of being a
[ __ ] tools and how you gonna call
someone a Twitter contest and see who's
a bigger [ __ ] tool but he's got that
little piece of hair under his litter so
bad sort of hat should if anyone's on
the tool contest I will win are you a
bigger tool than most I've had a lot of
breakfast okay it's got a soul patch
it's part of my appeal that is the tool
badge of honor isn't it the soul patch
and when you're in a name when you're in
a band called striper you do you wear
stripe yep so that's that's exhausted
that's the look though yeah it's a good
look that is a game yeah you're jealous
cuz only diagonal you were jealous cuz
you didn't think to wear stripes that's
what this is about
that's badass that reminds me of the
Lord like that makes me feel all
religious right and quit you in touch
with Jesus this monument I feel better
why they do you like that why did he say
you're a tool for what Jesus told him
it's a long story and I really don't
want to give them the time did you just
but you don't like each other he put out
a headline one saying that he was asked
to produce a Sebastian Bach record who
the [ __ ] do you think asked that
question could it be me what I hadn't
gotta say I never asked any guy in
Strieber to produce my record you didn't
know no I never did this is the way it
is right sorry
you know man you know there was another
interaction that is interested in in the
book okay
I think it was like 88 89 I couldn't
believe you were talking about seeing
gene Simmons yeah and gene Simmons like
and then this was like height of skid
row everything was going on and even
then it was when kiss was going through
there no makeup phase yeah
and gene was like kind of I want to say
insulting you but like reprimanding you
for drinking alcohols is Sebastian what
is that in your cup it grabs it Jack
Daniels how do you put this in your
system you're killing yourself like oh
my god are you corny like if it's a
[ __ ] old game of the Stone Age and
you're like the beer warnings the grease
Rangers corny yeah that's great but it
was just so funny to think is he's like
the biggest kiss me at Birth kid I love
it so the whole books like a love letter
to kiss of course yeah that but like the
fact that like gene wouldn't be like
well yeah maybe Sebastian when he's like
19 20 years old is enjoying himself he's
having a beverage you know they record
me a new [ __ ] he is
do you ever hope you do you ever get
talked before them another band did
without you but did you ever get to know
no [ __ ] that sucks
[ __ ] that's okay man [ __ ] I'm busy
enough believe me I'm busy whose idea
was the dust jacket for the book that
was my idea because as a kiss fan you
want a [ __ ] full pullout color poster
let me tell you something Dan Soder you
haven't seen this one yet
oh yeah that's a picture of me about 1
million years ago you know is that one
no you should not sleep is your penis
balls showing poison weed one my dad one
might go to that happy trail good one my
dad saw me on the cover
Rolling Stone I was so excited I call
home I go dad you see the cover of
Rolling Stone these phones are quiet as
the [ __ ] is that an armadillo when you
ban I got it from you
did you stuff for this picture is is
natural to me no stuff you can see
ridges I'm not that
telogen I don't use tapes for my vocals
I don't put anything in their hands that
is all-natural huh my hair's all real -
really believe it or not look at that
real deal look at that deal I didn't
even know that was a plus I'm old you
didn't know this is a poster - no I just
we should I didn't die every [ __ ]
issue Jim now you love that book yeah
I'm gonna get you - I'm gonna get you to
sign this I'm gonna put up on my ceiling
wait for the tape to give out oh yeah
back down to me come back down that's
like in David Lee Ross like you know
when I had women and children first I
had the poster him like chained up to
the fence with no shirt off that's not
weird at all yeah it is weird the
shirtless rock stars put this up there
was a time when that was metal yeah yeah
I was very chained to a feds with no
shirt on the I'll have a favorite poster
it was cool back it is so cool you are
so [ __ ] cool yeah yes certain things
just don't hold over no they in Heights
are a little weird is there anything you
didn't want to write about like is there
anything you're putting you know like
I'm gonna make this a book there's
finally there's a whole section of my
computer called cut out of what see
what's there well I don't this isn't
really a tell-all this is like a tells
some I see there was more sex in in a
previous version but why wouldn't you
put all the sexy because I would read it
back and it would read like and then she
reached down and unzipped my fly it's
romantic sexy oh yeah
felt like Donald Trump [ __ ] like I
grabbed her [ __ ] I'm like dude you
can't put that in your [ __ ] blood
ever do they ship don't you ever grab a
girl by the place guys don't need to
grab oh I see was offered strong in his
hand he never has needed wrap I accepted
the [ __ ] in my hand
yeah he's given to me drop it drop it
like a dog with a tennis ball drop it
drop it okay [ __ ] fetch
yeah are you ever gonna release another
book of all the salacious yeah you know
I don't
I believe sex stories with Sebastian
even Dora Collins has already said they
want another book yeah you could do a
cover like a romance novel with like a
billowy blouse oh yeah I think what I'd
really like to do is a travel log that
might on the surface sound boring but we
just did 40 gigs in the last two months
in seven countries we played Mexico City
like two nights ago and and people don't
[ __ ] get the like kanye west gets it
he's at home in bed yeah I'm on Sirius
radio I'm tired I'm thirsty
notice [ __ ] I was a [ __ ] role duders
a glass of water how was Mexico Mexico
is good it is scary it's grueling yeah
are you grueling if you cancel it where
you been on the road I mean I was
annoying right because he blocks out of
a show three songs in and then he
cancelled like 30 shows were laying like
in in Sudbury in the snow with the
lifting up [ __ ] on the ice and the
[ __ ] so I'm not lifting but yeah
somebody is but he he doesn't have any
equipment he doesn't have a band he's
got not Aegis him on a stage with a mic
not to be a prick but like I don't I
don't think that that guy or the
Kardashians like no they signed up for
like in this world you know what I'm
saying it's like they don't do anything
right well just like this name I want to
be a rock star we have a [ __ ] nice
time with that [ __ ] cancel all those
nothing easy as you think it is all
right how do you leave your [ __ ]
hiring it's grueling my thirsty talking
about your Thursday get a [ __ ] bottle
of water you don't even know what you're
talking about
right he might have mental problems but
that's a luxury he might sleep I think
I'm a [ __ ] mental [ __ ] thank you yeah
I think so it doesn't give me a ride to
cancel the gig but Ozzy Osbourne he's
real stable that's a good point yeah I
think I need awful [ __ ] on Ozzy's up
there shuffle around pee in his pants
does he urinate himself in here is if we
deploy as soon as Black Sabbath don't
I'm doing those solo record
I mean you've been on the road for
consistently 20 like 25 years 30 30
years there's no quitting you is there I
enjoy it I am what I really enjoy
specifically yes is touring by bus you
like that I love the bus I love being on
the bus rolling down the road I don't
like flying at 9:00 in the morning to
the gig and getting to the hotel you
know when you're on the road and you're
doing flying yeah that sucks going to
the airport all the time I like the bus
the bus is like a cocoon right that's
like what Dan was saying about these van
that he takes to set mmhmm yeah where I
get to hear poems
that's right other cool things you guys
write poems no uh they don't pay do you
share the bus with the other band
members you get your own uh oh I got my
own like suite in the back okay like a
bedroom is slide out that'd be kind of
fun to be on the bus I've never done a
tour bus but it would be it would suck
to share it with people or hate all that
would you want to bring Jim with you on
the bus yeah he's a funny man I follow
him on Twitter thank you yeah there it
is well listen everybody I love your
stuff on Twitter
thank you my laughs at high five psyche
bug everybody gets a book man it's
called Sebastian Bach 18 in life on Skid
Row it's out today sign Amazon yeah
you're doing signings and yeah all kinds
of stuff all over the place get it in
Brooklyn you sure you're not going to
get exhausted and have to cancel them
I'm thirsty tonight say beetus in
Brooklyn tomorrow book ends in Ridgewood
acceptable thursday is a Eatontown he's
got a whole bunch go to our website you
can go to amigo to Sebastian's Twitter
at Sebastian Bach on Twitter Facebook
yeah he's got everywhere he's doing
Illinois Michigan st. Louis Arizona LA
and Vegas that the Hard Rock December 70
there's a shitload of book signing so go
meet Sebastian buy a book and get it
signed yeah Jim let me sign yours right
now Thank You Sebastian Bach